you look fabulous does it feel good to
be back back in the swing of things yes
it does I'm back at work I'm here
tonight promoting this wonderful cause
and yeah it feels awesome
are you kidding how did this come about
this partnership sex reached out to me
to be their ambassador this year and I
you know frankly I had been approached
by a number of organizations many of
them are wonderful organizations this to
me made the most sense for a number of
reasons first of all the reach that they
do through key to the cure is far and
and so it's it seemed to be very
impactful as a result and of course the
t-shirt that you're wearing this on sale
at Saks the 100% of the proceeds goes to
benefit the charity that I designated
which is called the eros Foundation
which provides breast reconstructive
surgery for those women who can't either
afford it or whose insurance can't cover
it and to me that seemed like a really
good area that could use some help
because it is and the idea of somebody
not being able to get reconstruction if
they want it and plenty of women choose
not to do it but if they want it is
unconscionable
so airs fills in that gap well I know
that you mentioned when you announced
publicly about your cancer that you said
thankfully I have a good family I have a
good team of doctors and I have
insurance correct
you know that was an important part yes
well the healthcare is certainly front
and center in my mind and I think that
you know everyone and I mean everyone
should have access to health care and
it's not for the if health insurance
isn't for the rich and privileged only
it should not be and it should be for
all people and so I feel very strongly
about that and and I I know the folks
here do too
so now that your treatments are behind
you you did share with your fans a video
that your son's made for you
when you were having your last chemo
treatment yes where were you when you
got this video and you know how did that
make you feel trying to remember where I
was did they send it to you via your
phone you know I think they sent it to
me when I was actually getting my last
chemotherapy so I saw it that's probably
why I don't remember very well because I
simply medicated but I'm actually not
kidding but I know the video of course I
just don't remember the actual moment
when I saw it that's probably the reason
why yeah it was so cute and you were
able to share it with your fans did that
mean a lot yes
you know I originally I'll be honest
with you I something like this journey
that I've been on would normally I
wouldn't share such a private thing
publicly but given the fact that
it just so happened that I mean I knew
this would get out there because we had
to shut down production for a number of
months in order to accommodate my my
situation so then I thought okay well
I'm just going to embrace this and and
attack it and try to do with the sense
of humor and so and then it kind of I
was actually really pleased with the
reaction because I think it was bullying
- the response I've gotten is that it's
buoying - people who are battling cancer
and it had a sense of humor and it had a
kind of a kick cancer in the ass point
of view which I have Michael Jackson
track so right exactly
speaking of veep you're now filming your
last season at B but I'm curious since
now that you've had that experience with
another successful show Seinfeld and you
closed that and put a bow on top of it
are you approaching this one any
differently well I'm savoring every
second of it so and I savored every
second and Seinfeld - but I'm more
cognizant than ever that this is a an
unusual thing to have all the elements
come together as as well as they have
like during Seinfeld it's really kind of
lightning in a bottle as they say so I'm
relishing every blasted second
[Music]